how did the US government respond to an
unprecedented germ assault in late two
thousand one next on book TV Washington
Post editor Maryland Thompson discusses
the Keller strain her new book examining
this still unsolved anthrax case and
assesses the possibility of a future
attack it's 50 minutes thank you all for
coming it's a privilege for me to be
here to introduce tonight's speaker
Maryland Thompson is certainly an
impressive person and has impressive
credentials as you can see from your
program she's an award-winning
investigative reporter and editor for
one of the most widely read and
influential newspapers in the world the
Washington Post she has won a team
Pulitzer Prize for public service
reporting not once but twice and for
those of you who don't know the Pulitzer
Prize is journalism's most prestigious
honor her work has helped uncover
numerous corporate and government
scandals and she has been called I love
this one a Washington spin doctors worst
nightmare she's also the author of three
books now and will soon add to her
resume a teaching appointment at
Princeton University which is not a bad
school so see what you can do with a
Clemson degree that's where that's where
a Clemson education can take you folks
that's right because Maryland is also a
Clemson graduate and in fact got her
start in journalism right here on the
tiger staff so you just never know and
to prove that she's definitely come back
home we even have I think some of her
family members in the audience tonight
her parents Hugh and Jesse walser of
Greenville are here welcome glad you're
able to be with us tonight but seriously
while we're all very proud of Maryland's
accomplishments and
and and what that has meant for Clemson
and we're delighted to have her back on
campus and hopes you'll return many
times that's really not why we're here
we're here because Maryland's latest
book is has been called a wake-up call
and must read for a country still trying
to figure out how to live with terrorism
this just release book literally has
only been out for a few weeks now it's
called the killer strain and tracks and
a government exposed and it's truly a
non-stop thriller that rivals anything
hollywood could come up with but
unfortunately it's all true this story
really did happen and we're all still
trying to sort out how it happened and
what we did right and what we did wrong
and whether or not it could ever happen
again and Maryland's book is going to
help us answer some of those questions
it is meticulously researched it's
well-written and it's unyielding in its
efforts to shine a spotlight on to how
we as a government and a nation
responded to this bio terrorism threat
as one reviewer said Maryland Thompson
has done a tremendous public service so
ladies and gentlemen Maryland Thompson
Thank You Kathy thank all of you for
coming nothing like talking about
bioterrorism on a beautiful spring
evening as Kathy told you I am a
graduate of Clemson class of 74 some of
you may have heard of me I'm the only
Clemson graduate to have never attended
a an athletic event when I when I was
here I've spent most of my time in the
offices of the tiger where I really
learned the ropes of journalism and
managed to put it to great use
throughout college back then we used to
climb nine flights of stairs in a very
dank stairway in something called
johnston hall which i find now has
completely vanished from the face of the
earth as perhaps it should have it was
quite a place and the journalism that
was practiced at the tiger was fairly
radical for for its time and for the
Clemson campus we were sort of the
liberal voice in a fairly conservative
student body but it was really an
intellectual center at the time and it
somehow managed to produce a host of
very good journalists who've gone on to
jobs at very prestigious news
organizations around the country just to
name a few my brother Jim law sir who
went on to become an assistant managing
editor at The Charlotte Observer of
which which is where he works now rando
Ashley from the Atlanta
journal-constitution Jack Lynch who now
works on the financial section at the
New York Times Tom pretty at night
Ritter and Dick carpet lien who didn't
go into journalism but apparently went
into politics and has been doing quite
well here in the state Democratic Party
I think of Clemson often because there
were some very seminal influences from
Clemson who affected my life one of them
unfortunately couldn't be here tonight
but dr. Lewis Henry who was the faculty
advisor to the tiger for many years and
who was a voice of inspiration for me
personally and also dr. Malcolm ossory
who was an English professor who I think
of often when i try to try to understand
how i came to love the language and
writing as much as i do dr. us recall
taught a course and something as obscure
as Victorian poetry and actually managed
to make me love it and think of him
often very fondly and of course my
parents to whom the book is dedicated
have traveled from Greenville to be here
tonight and hopefully they'll be proud
of this book which is dedicated to them
I even see my sister in law and other
familiar faces thank you for coming we
live in an age in which deadly pathogens
are on the loose and as a result all of
us must live in fear this is not a
figment of my imagination it is true and
I think we see it happening more and
more as recent events have have shown us
so vividly just recently in my own
experience I have a reporter at the post
who produced a two-part series on the
South African biological weapons program
which was disbanded about a decade ago
but continues to be a concern because
the pathogens that were being used in
the laboratories therefore some really
strange and dark projects were turned
over not to a state-controlled
institution but to private individuals
and so these people literally
have agents capable of wiping out a huge
city sitting at sometimes in their own
homes or storage facilities I'm sure
that you've all followed the SARS
epidemic very closely and of course
there was an initial fear that that too
was a bioterror act it took weeks to
wipe out that speculation but it shows
again how prevalent thinking about
bioterror has become we've also watched
the debacle over the smallpox vaccine
our hope early this year that we could
vaccinate every essential medical
personnel who might be called into duty
in a biological crisis unfortunately the
faith and government institutions and
health institutions in this country is
so low at this point that only something
like 25,000 of the 250,000 people who we
wanted to take this vaccine have stepped
forward to be vaccinated I became
interested in the anthrax letters not as
a reporter but as an editor and once
again I was kind of watching from afar
as one of my reporters joby warrick went
down the trail of trying to figure out
something about who could have done this
terrible crime joby began gathering
information on something called the
aimed strain of anthrax because it was
very clearly identified early after the
first letter surfaced in Florida that
this was the aim strain which is one of
89 types of anthrax and a very special
type that was used almost exclusively in
US military research facilities Joe be
managed to get from Fort Detrick which
is a highly sensitive place outside of
Washington a list of all the
laboratories to which they had
officially sent
strain it was a short list which gave us
hope that perhaps this could really be
tracked very easily but then we learned
the other side of the story which was
the official routing of pathogens is
only what's on paper pathogens in
laboratories are passed around pretty
much like baseball cards and have been
for years among scientists who are doing
research on these obscure bacteria just
a few weeks ago the Wall Street Journal
underscored this problem again with a
front-page article about a doctor in
Texas who had returned on a commercial
aircraft after 911 with files of plague
germs that he brought back from travels
in Tanzania all of this hidden and
undetected even in our new heightened
security state the fact that this was
the same strain could not be traced
easily really bothered me and I became
even more concerned when a top FBI
official was called the Capitol Hill and
grilled by a Senate committee and asked
to give some estimate of the number of
labs in the US that might have some
access to the aim strain his answer was
to shrug his shoulders and say we simply
have no idea it could be thousands we
had no way of knowing where this
material had come from and our
custodianship of this material had been
so lacks that it was very simply easy to
fall into the wrong hands I became even
more alarmed watching from afar when a
US official stated unequivocally that
there had been no powdered anthrax or
anthrax that could somehow be called wet
nized anthrax made in this country since
President Nixon disbanded our own
weapons program back in nineteen
sixty-nine this was said with certainty
many times by top officials in the
military and yet along the course of
several weeks of reporting there was a
backtracking and the army suddenly said
well you know there have been small
quantities of aerosol anthrax made at
Dugway proving ground out in Utah this
seemed to me to be quite an admission
and again at this point the army had
kind of closed down and simply refused
to say where those aerosol quantities
might have been shipped once again you
know thwarting any attempt to find out
where this stuff might have come from
and who might have had it the postal
service and its behavior as a series of
letters passed through the system
killing two postal workers in the
Brentwood facility near Washington which
is where of course I work and live the
Postal Service's behavior was
inexcusable we simply could tell that
they had not taken precautions to get
workers out of a plant that was
obviously contaminated by anthrax and
while people were getting sick and
showing up in emergency rooms
bureaucrats in Washington were debating
well do we shut the facility down and
how much would that cost us and what
would that do to the mail system and
Mail is so vital to the lifeblood of
this nation how can we possibly shut
down any part of the system and so this
debate raged while people died I also
became increasingly alarmed as a citizen
when we began talking of going to war
with Iraq
over its biological weapons capabilities
and chemical weapons capabilities this
was of concern to me I mean there was
still debate about whether we would be
able to find these Arsenal's once we got
into Iraq but what we knew from our own
monitoring of Iraq over the last decade
was that they had secured pathogens
including anthrax in a number of
different strains from a US company
which had shipped this material to them
with full approval from the US
Department of Commerce to me it was
unbelievable that we were in essence
going to war over something that we had
helped to create an anxiety that we had
helped create and so I set out to write
this book government accountability is
one of the benchmarks of my work over
the past 20 years and I decided that it
was time to ask hard questions of people
who were on the front lines in these
attacks but I wanted to do it and
present it to readers in a way where
they would actually begin to learn and
care about the subject of bioterrorism
because I became convinced through my
early research that this was not a
problem that was going to be a one-time
thing it's something that's going to
surface again either in hoaxes or real
life and that we needed to do all we
could to make sure that people knew and
that government institutions were aware
in my early reporting I decided that I
was going to try to focus on some
central characters to help me tell the
story this is mainly a writing technique
but it's also a way to humanize
something that seems kind of cold and
distant to the average person and so I
set out to find these characters I
decided that I wanted to focus on a Vic
some of the attacks and I was lucky
enough to meet and get to know Leroy
Richmond who is a veteran postal worker
more than 30 years service and who
worked at the Brentwood facility near
Washington doing express mail a job that
he absolutely loved and believed that he
was providing a huge service to
customers mr. Richmond became deathly
ill with inhalation anthrax during a
period when the postal service was
realizing that anthrax was in that plan
and yet it was not getting the workers
out he was asked to clean up behind
machine 17 this was not even his normal
job responsibilities machine 17 is a
huge grinding piece of equipment that
processes millions of pieces of mail a
day and does so at a very rapid pace
Joseph ker seen one of mr. Richmond's
buddies had worked that machine during
the day shift and he had gone home and
mr. Richmond was asked to go over and
clean up there was some debris trash
boxes around the Machine and he was
asked to do sort of janitorial service
and so he did because he always did what
he was asked only in doing so he inhaled
enough anthrax spores to contract the
most fatal form of anthrax disease which
is a horrible illness a riff and a
really fatal illness in a high
percentage of cases mr. Christine was
not so lucky he left machine 17 went
home became sick thought he had the flu
which is characteristic of all anthrax
patients and went to the emergency room
and died from the same piece of
equipment
mr. Richmond agreed to tell his story
because he had become so outraged
quietly outraged he's not a very
political man by the fact that he and
the other workers in Brentwood were left
exposed to this material that he really
wanted something done about it and he
saw talking to a reporter one way to try
to get the story out I also stumbled
across John Iselle who is a scientist at
Fort Detrick with the US Army Medical
Research Institute I read about the
opening of the letter that showed up in
the senate office building the so-called
dashiell letter and i had read about the
scientist who tore it open in the lab
under heavy heavy protection and soft
spores come out so rapidly and so
profusely that they ricocheted against
the stainless steel walls of the lab so
I called John Iselle not really
expecting him to want to talk to a
reporter because Fort Detrick is not
really that kind of place and much to my
surprise he did want to talk about it
and he wanted to share some of his
experiences again because he realized
that he had been part of a real
precedent-setting event and that perhaps
through public education the next time
things would be managed differently so
john told me the story of a scientist
working on the front lines in the
laboratory with a pathogen that was so
incredibly virulent that when he looked
at it he came out of the lab and told
his bosses that he had just looked in
the face of Satan I also managed to get
full cooperation from dr. Jeffrey
Copelan who at the time was the director
of the Centers for Disease Control in
Atlanta a very important job in a very
important man
who's basically dedicated his whole life
to public medicine I thought dr.
Copeland's story was incredibly
interesting because he he was in essence
a political victim of the sensitive he
ended up resigning his job a job he
loved and job he was very good at
because he felt so outraged by the
political aftermath of the attacks and
the fact that his judgment was
questioned the doctors judgment was
questioned in all cases and so he told
his story to which was a wonderful story
about political pressures and how they
can affect a public health agency what I
learned in the course of this reporting
through these three very helpful men was
a tale about an administration in
Washington that was real really more
concerned about tamping down public
hysteria than it was about getting out
real facts and real medical information
to the public there were justifiable
reasons for this perhaps because if you
recall the anthrax letters surfaced
right after 911 the most horrendous
terrorist attack in our history and so
the administration and some of the large
federal agencies really didn't want
things to get any worse and they
certainly didn't want the public to be
hysterical about going to the mailbox
and opening mail and finding something
deadly inside it so there was an
elaborate campaign to spin and to
minimize the consequences in danger of
these attacks
but the problem was this was taking
place at the same time that quick
thinking and helpful public information
could have really helped the situation
our public health system during these
attacks was fractured and poorly
coordinated doctors had to go back to
their medical textbooks to even figure
out what anthrax was in some cases
patients would stumble into the hospital
and they would find a doctor who was
alert enough to remember oh yeah I
remember that there was this bizarre
bacteria that caused the lungs to widen
but in many cases the doctors didn't
remember this they didn't they they had
no reason to have that information at
their fingertips and patients went
undiagnosed the communication between
the local agencies and the federal
agencies was very poor and for good
reason there had not been enough money
invested in such basic things as
telephone lines and fax machines and
other forms of communication the CDC it
turned out had operated under an
abundance of caution rather than giving
the quick response and sound medical
advice that was called for everyone at
the CDC realized that they had made
errors in the critical days of these
incidents and they want to do better and
they've been trying to do better the FBI
was very poorly equipped to deal with a
complex investigation involving science
and technology at the highest levels
they had to rely instead of their own
experts on outside labs and it became
incredibly incredibly ironic
when some of the very people that they
were relying on for advice had to be
added to the list of possible suspects
who were technologically capable of
committing these crimes so the message
that was conveyed to the public overall
was that there was really no agency
worthy of our public trust in this first
bioterror attack on American soil the
public didn't know didn't know who to
turn to law enforcement was stumbling
public health agencies were stumbling
and all of it orchestrated from the
highest levels of the White House to try
to tamp down the fear and panic so I
think things really escalated because of
the way it was handled politically so
what lessons have we learned well there
are signs of progress anyone who's
watched the response to the SARS
epidemic in this country can see a huge
difference in the way that the Centers
for Disease Control has responded and
the information flow that has come out
of that agency you can go on the CDC
website which is a great fountain of
knowledge about diseases and just fine
dreams of material on SARS everything
you could possibly want to know how to
take care of a patient who has sars what
to do if you think you have sars if the
list goes on and on and all of that is a
very deliberate effort by the CDC to
shake itself out of the complacency and
the slowness that contributed to the
problems in 2001
the Postal Service has made huge
investments monetary investments and
trying to buy equipment that will help
detect bio agents in postal facilities
some of these are now being tested I
believe they have a pilot test of about
seven post offices where this equipment
is being installed they've also tried
through a public education campaign that
all of you may be aware of to teach
people how to handle suspicious mail
what to do if you should go to the
mailbox and see a letter that just
doesn't look right or that has tape on
the back or no return address or any of
the other distinctive features that may
mark someone you know doing something
out of place here but my conclusion
after spending about a year on this
project was that dealing with bio
terrorism is not just a matter of
throwing money at the problem which is
something that Washington is certainly
shown its willingness to do because this
really in the end is not about money
it's not about money that's being spent
it's about heightened vigilance
preparedness proactiveness by citizens
and it also demands that citizens hold
these agencies accountable for making
improvements that we don't just let it
drop and act like it will never happen
again and there's a need for critical
thinking and real common sense at all
levels of government I liked from the
book of the story of a Senate chief of
staff named Luke Alby who's the chief of
staff for Senator Leahy who was one of
the targets of one of these contaminated
ladders Luke Alby was the highest paid
ber of the Senate staff and he began to
get worried about anthrax in the mail
when he's first heard about it when he
heard about the first case which
surfaced in Florida with a photo
journalist Bob Stevens he tracked it
very carefully all of his instincts were
heightened he watched when the next set
of letters showed up in New York
addressed to Tom Brokaw dan Rather Peter
Jennings and Luke Albie wrote a memo to
Senator Leahy which seemed to be really
ahead of the curve it said to Senator
Leahy I've been watching these anthrax
letters show up around the country and
frankly I'm concerned that a politician
could be the next target and I'm not
just concerned about any politician I'm
concerned about you because you have
been one of the most visible figures on
Capitol Hill during the passage of the
u.s. Patriot Act which was a hugely
controversial piece of legislation and
so Lou Cal be made a command decision
that until this fear was over no more
mail would come into the Senate office
without his supervision and what he
would do instead of sending a young
intern down to bring up the bags of mail
which are the lifeblood of every Senate
office instead of sending the lowest
paid worker down to get this he would go
down and he would sit in the mailroom
and he would sort through the mail he
would throw out anything that looked
junkie or suspicious set it aside turn
it over to law enforcement and then he
would bring back only the critical
letters that he thought the senator was
going to need to know about and he would
go into a room shut the doors open the
windows and sort through each of these
letters by hand himself
he never expected anyone else to do it
for him but he is now regarded in that
office as a huge hero as someone who
really by his own pre-emptive action may
have saved lives so I'm happy to take
questions I know we have a few from the
students hi mrs. Thompson hi my name is
Elizabeth I wanted to ask you what are
the implications in terms of American
preparedness post the anthrax letters
and also how do you feel the press as a
whole hindered or helped the
investigation the criminal investigation
yes I think the press as a whole has
been largely shut out of the criminal
investigation which has been one of the
more interesting criminal investigations
in my memory it started with the FBI
reaching out for help writing letters to
everyone who belonged to the American
Society for Microbiology which is 30,000
plus members asking them for tips and
leads and good information about
possible suspects and then they close
down the FBI completely closed down
they've given out very little
information about the status of this
case they've kept all their fax very
close to the vest and the media because
of the difficulty in trying to address
that situation has stopped writing about
it and it's very rare to see anything at
this point about what's going on in one
of the largest criminal inquiries in the
country so the media should be doing a
more aggressive job not that the media
can solve this case it is an incredibly
complex case but certainly they should
be again watching the FBI and demanding
that the FBI do his job my name is Sunil
my question threat of a next in
biological warfare what effective
preventive measures any government can
depend on to protect its larger
population at risk like any kind of
effective protection is based on the
knowledge of the agent that the enemy is
going to use have so many which used as
deadly biological weapons how effective
would be a program like preventive
vaccination and antibiotic therapy
that's a very good question because yes
the treatment differs in many cases for
different agents and so you are you you
are faced with the issue of how many
vaccines would we expect someone to take
for these agents or you know that the
experts in bio terrelonge a great long
ago have drawn up list of what they
consider to be the most likely agents to
be used because of the ease of access
the ease of cultivation is the ease of
dispersal and so we've basically
operated in our early preparedness
efforts from kind of a short list of the
agents that we think are the most likely
to to be used the problem is even when
we have vaccines again that they help
the public trust and the health agencies
is so low that nobody wants to take them
or use them the smallpox thing being one
example the anthrax vaccine being
another I devote a good part of a
chapter in the book to talking about the
political controversy of that vaccine
which has been effectively used for the
military for 30 years and yet is not
available for the American public and
even if it were there's so many
questions that have arisen about it's
safe safety and F
see that it's doubtful that many people
would line up to get it I don't know the
answer to your question but I think that
that's certainly a question and an issue
that an agency like the Centers for
Disease Control and the department of
health and human services should be
wrestling with right now I'm a door
tiger lady yes if anthrax or another
disease were to come into the United
States and knowingly based on your
research and things are happening today
and the central focus on terrorism and
bioterrorism how do you feel a nation
would react and how do you feel that the
media and government would react if
there were another incident yes I hope
that things would be better but I'm not
convinced that they would be I think
that we really you know are not yet are
not ready yet to effectively handle
another bioterror release that might
involve thousands of casualties there
are efforts underway at every level
including local hospitals state
emergency planning agencies and
certainly federal government through the
Homeland Security Department to try to
improve I think we just need to hope
that that progress comes before another
madman manages to unleash one of these
things
so hard to believe that during an age of
people who strap bombs to their bodies
and go into crowds that we might not see
a change of strategies with pathogens
rather than thinking of those that can
be handled in aerosol or and water come
out with human vectors that would
voluntarily go in and infect large
populations with things like Ebola I've
certainly read speculation that that
could happen you know the short answer
is in this world anything is possible
and we've seen that through the suicide
bombers I mean there are people willing
to lose their lives for a cause that to
me would be a possibility I don't think
that the FBI has really tuned into that
possibility at this point they're much
more concerned about other forms of
potential release but it's an idea
yes ma'am I'm Rebecca Jimenez I'm with
the American Academy for veterinary
disaster medicine could you please speak
to any information that you found with
the veterinary community which runs into
anthrax a little more commonly than
medical doctors could you please speak
to that in anything that you found out
your research um well have you excuse me
but have you by any chance taken the end
anthrax vaccine yeah yeah the thing that
was interesting to me was that we do
have in our population base a large
number of people who have been taking
this vaccine and apparently you know
surviving and and living good lives so
that we don't have to be quite as afraid
of the the actual vaccine as as we do of
the event itself and veterinarians are
certainly one of those groups they've
been taking this vaccine for many years
with great effect and are protected to a
much greater extent than the American
public the same is true with military
personnel as you say for 30 years John
is El the scientist who I focused on in
the book I mean he's had the vaccine and
the booster shots for most of his
professional life he still however was
terrified by the level of the material
that he saw in the lab and there's an
incredible incident in the book in which
you know he comes out after seeing the
face of Satan in this envelope and
although he was wearing protective
clothing and had the vaccine and you
know had it had all the protections that
we could offer at this point he went he
went over and mixed a solution of bleach
and water and snorted it out of the fear
that perhaps a stray spore had gone up
his nose it was that scary sensation and
then he immediately went on cipro so
there is protection available the
question is is it good enough and our
enter people going to have access to it
which in the case of the anthrax vaccine
they don't at this stage my question and
you may have answered it in your book
but I haven't had a chance to read it is
what would you attribute the fact that
there has not been any other incidents
two of the protect of this particular
anthrax variety did you say the media is
sort of stopped reporting about it the
criminal investigation is supposedly
continuing but it's pretty close to the
vest well my my sources at the FBI would
tell you that the fact that there hasn't
been another spate of letters similar to
the ones that surfaced in 2001 is
because they've had the right people
under scrutiny since those attacks thus
they have thwarted any additional action
it would be speculation on my part but
that's certainly an interesting theory
hello my name is Joan I wondered in your
research and and investigating do you
have you come to a conclusion do you
think it's an individual or a group of
people that instigated this or do you
have any suspicions or does the FBI
other than a disgruntled scientists that
we read about my conclusion based on
reviewing the evidence is that this was
probably the act of a mastermind with
accomplices it would it would have been
very difficult for one individual to
pull off this crime without some sort of
help even to the level of a person
willing to go put a letter in the
mailbox at a location a hundred and
fifty miles away there had it seems that
there had to be some some helping hands
in this and I know that the FBI has
certainly gone down that path so far
they have not named any other
individuals that they regard as
potential accomplices
sure do you think that any other
administration could have done a better
job given the information that they had
at the time that's a very good question
I mean it would be interesting to think
of that in hindsight if you talk to
officials of the Clinton administration
they would certainly tell you that they
would have done a better job but I mean
there was a shock element to this and
there was as I said in my remarks there
was the horror of what had happened a
month earlier and so yeah I do cut a
little slack for that in trying to
address how the administration dealt
with it there's a horrifying incident on
top of another horrifying incident what
another have done better I really don't
know it all behind site at this point
in your book you spend a lot of time on
Stephen hath fell and the list of lies
and exaggerations on his resume and yet
he still got a very high security
clearance and now is of course a person
of interest yes how could it is the
security system at places like Fort
Detrick so lacks that they they don't
even check on people who have graciously
expanded their resumes well that's a
very good question you know if you talk
to the people at Fort Detrick or at the
US Army Medical Research Institute they
believe they have some of the tightest
security in America and certainly when I
went there to visit and to research I
was subjected to very high levels of
security at the front desk and
throughout the facility the thing that
that seemed to have worked in Steven
Hatfield situation is that there was
series of Lies built upon lies that
allowed him to get that kind of access I
mean for instance he he was a actually a
grant a grantee from another agency the
federal the national office of child
development that's how he originally
came into the federal sphere in order to
get into that agency he submitted a
phony doctor'll certificate so and they
bought it and they gave him the access
and then once he was in it built one
thing built upon another if you go to
Dietrich and say how could had Phil have
ever gained access their answer is well
how did he ever gain access back at NIH
when he was given access there and given
security clearance at other places so it
was one built upon another
it's it shows a manipulation of the
system in other words
I ran into enormous obstacles with the
official federal agency officers for
instance I tried unsuccessfully to get
documents from the Environmental
Protection Agency about its cleanup of
the heart senate office building which i
was really interested in is kind of a
case study because that the cleanup of
these buildings is going to be one of
the legacies of the attacks they're
still sitting there contaminated in
Washington New Jersey Florida I ran into
a total roadblock and I worked on the
book for close to a year and employed at
one point a lawyer to try to help me
wrestle records out of the EPA and I
ended the project still having gotten
nothing so it's very frustrating because
as you know after nine eleven getting
documents how the government became even
harder than it ever was and it's always
been difficult so from agency to agency
there were there were battles it was
incredibly difficult to for instance to
get a sit-down interview with tommy
Thompson who I felt was a vital part of
the story but you had to just keep at it
keep at it and when the project was
finished some of it was still left
undone
any questions about my clemson years I
really didn't go to an athletic event
Marilyn if you will come back this fall
we can take care of that we will take
you to a football game how about that
but in the meantime we do have a small
gift of appreciation and we hope that
you'll come back soon and I also want to
thank everyone for coming tonight and I
hope that you'll stay and join us
Marilyn will be here to sign her book
and you can ask a few more questions and
she has got some great stories we were
getting regular before we got into the
serious subject matter about some of her
other adventures here and at the
newspaper but again thank you so much
for coming and we thoroughly enjoyed it
and I hope you'll join us out at the
book signing thank you
you
the line
and
Marilyn Thompson is author of the killer
strain anthrax and a government exposed
it's published by Harper Collins on the
web at HarperCollins com